>> MR. LEWIS
>> THANK YOU FOR COMING IN WITH
YOUR ASSOCIATES.
I KNOW THIS IS HARD TO HEAR BUT
WE NEED TO MAKE SOME SERIOUS
DECISIONS ABOUT YOUR MOTHER'S
HEALTH.
LET'S BE HONEST, SHE IS GETTING
ON IN YEARS.
>> OH, THAT.
OKAY, I SEE HOW IT IS.
I SEE HOW IT IS.
WELL YOUR MAMA SO OLD HER LAST
NAME IS OSAURUS.
>> NO, IT WASN'T AN INSULT.
I'M JUST SAYING YOUR MOTHER'S
CONDITION IS DETERIORATING.
>> OKAY, THAT'S A COLD ONE.
I SEE HOW IT IS.
OKAY, YOUR MAMA SO OLD IN HER
HISTORY CLASS THEY JUST WROTE
DOWN WHAT THEY WERE DOING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> MR. LEWIS, THIS ISN'T AN
INSULT CONTEST.
NOT ONLY YOUR MOTHER ELDERLY BUT
ALSO HER ABILITY TO WALK IS
CURRENTLY BEING AFFECT WILL BY
HER WEIGHT.
>> OH, SEE, OKAY.
IT JUST GOT REAL.
>> NO, I'M NOT INSULTING HER I'M
TRYING TO TELL YOU --
>> YOUR MAMA IS SO FAT WHEN SHE
GO TO THE MOVIE THEATRE THEY
MOVE OUT OF HER WAY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> YOUR MOTHER NEEDS TO MANAGE
HER WEIGHT OR THERE CAN BE SOME
REAL PROBLEMS.
>> OH, OKAY.
ALL RIGHT, YEAH, YEAH.
YOUR MA IS SO FAT SHE NEEDS A
LOT LATITUDE AND LONGITUDE.
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A WOMAN
WHO TOOK CARE OF HER AT LEAST
YOU CAN TAKE OF HER IN HER OLD
AGE AND TAKE THIS SERIOUSLY.
>> I'M SORRY.
>> I'M SORRY I LOST MY TEMPER.
>> NO, REALLY, DOCTOR, I GUESS I
WAS JUST JOKING AROUND BECAUSE I
KNOW HER CONDITION IS REALLY
SERIOUS AND I DON'T KNOW -- I
GUESS HUMOR IS THE ONLY WAY I
CAN REALLY DEAL WITH IT.
I JUST KNOW THAT SHE SAID SO
MANY TIMES SHE DOESN'T WANT
ANYTHING INVASIVE DONE.
>> REALLY, I WAS NOT AWARE.
THAT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE SHE
DID NOT MENTION THAT TO ME IN
OUR PREVIOUS CONVERSATION.
OF COURSE IT WAS DIFFICULT TO
HEAR HER WITH MY [BLEEP] IN HER
MOUTH.
[ SILENCE ]
>> SNAP, MR. LEWIS.
OH, SNAP.
NOW, LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
PROCEDURE.
>> HELLO EVERYBODY OUT THERE